you spent a lot of your childhood with
your grandfather on a ranch here in
Texas and I heard you had a a lot of
work to do around the ranch so what's
the coolest job you remember doing there
wow coolest um most interesting most
memorable most memorable it was a it was
real it's a real working Ranch um my and
I I spent all my Summers on that ranch
from Age 4 to 16 and my grandfather was
really taking me those in the summers in
the in the early Summers he was letting
me pretend to help on the ranch cuz of
course a four-year-old is a burden not a
help in real life he really just
watching me and taking care of me um and
he was doing that because my mom was so
young she had me when she was 17 and so
he was sort of giving her a break and my
grandmother and my grandfather would
take me for these Summers but as I got a
little older actually was helpful on the
ranch and I loved it I was out there
like my grandfather had a huge influence
on me huge factor in my life I did all
the jobs you would do on a ranch I've
fixed windmills and laid fences and
pipelines and you know done all the
things that any Rancher would do
vaccinated the animals everything um uh
but we had a you know my grandfather
after my grandmother died um I was about
12 and I kept coming to the ranch so was
then it was just him and me just the two
of us and he was completely addicted to
the soap opera the days of our lives and
we would go back to the ranch house
every day around 1 p.m. or so to watch
Days of Our Lives uh like Sands through
an hourglass so are the days of our
lives just the image of that the two
sitting there watching
slow had big crazy dogs it was really a
very formative experience for me but the
key thing about it for me the the great
gift I got from it was that my
grandfather was so resourceful you know
he did everything himself he made his
own Veterinary tools he would make
needles to suture the cattle up with he
would find a little piece of wire and
heat it up and pound it thin and drill a
hole in it and sharpen it so you know
you learn different things um on a ranch
than you would learn you know growing up
in a city so self-reliance yeah like
figing out that you can solve problems
with enough persistence and Ingenuity
and
my grandfather bought a D6 bulldozer
which is a big bulldozer and he got it
for like $5,000 cuz it was completely
broken down it was like a
1955 caterpillar D6 bulldozer knew it
would have cost I don't know more than
$100,000 and we spent an entire summer
fixing like repairing that bulldozer
we'd you know use mail order to to buy
big gears for the transmission and
they'd show up they'd be too heavy to
move so we'd have to build a crane you
know just that kind of kind of that
problem solving mentality um he had it
so powerfully you know he he did all of
his own uh he just he didn't pick up the
phone and call somebody he would figure
it out on his own he doing his own
Veterinary work you know but just the
image of the two of you fixing a D6
bulldozzer and then going in for a
little break at 1 pm to watch so laying
on the floor that's how he watched TV he
was a really really remarkable guy
that's how I imagine Clint Eastwood
also in all those westerns when he's
when he's not doing what he's doing he's
just watching soap
opers